so look what just
to the office today Concepcion to
boxing should be
now I can find John John oh there you
are hey what's up buddy Concepcion -
comes out in two weeks and I don't know
what girl I'm gonna mane and you got
Tori on one hand but then there's Ellie
and I just can't decide well decide
quick because we just got this greetings
everyone this is John from Atlas and it
is indeed a great day here because we
have done third up the conception to
leaders box not just three DS flavor but
also PlayStation Vita super excited to
have these in game launches April 15th
which is just about a week away so let's
take a look at what's inside shall we
bust out the trusty finger cutter try
and not cut ourselves open which has
happened before and that's why there are
special rules in place you can't see it
but there's actually someone Washington
making sure it make sure I don't cut
myself open right now we have here you
have the box itself and the 10 track CD
soundtrack which is full of j-rock
goodness like congratulations on your
new arrival which hopefully is played in
the background right now is your CD
soundtrack or
now let's take a look at what's in the
box what's in the box you'll call I
believe my last video for etching untold
I had a little bit of mishaps with
getting the cartridge out so let's hope
that doesn't happen this time I quit I
got a job I got it thanks John so yes
here is your conception to cartridge
lovely box art and inside you'll find
the Club Nintendo card make sure and get
a close-up on it please so no one steals
our Club Nintendo number you also find
this handy dandy little art insert two
beautiful heart so that was the 3ds
version but let's look at the Vita now
the Vita thing is a first of its kind I
guarantee you will never seen a Vita box
like this before because Atlas came up
with it cuz we were awesome like that
and because you know how much all of you
guys love these cool Cluckers things so
let's take a look inside again you have
your soundtrack and the Vita box
all right oops you don't enjoy the smell
of new plastic in ink you miss out on
the fine things in life so here's the
Vida box but the big question is is the
VTech cartridge easier to get out than
the 30s cartridge yes it is so there you
have the unboxing for the Nintendo 3ds
and PS Vita version of conception -
hopefully you guys have had a chance to
check out the demo already if you if you
have not it is on PlayStation Network
and the eShop for a Nintendo 3ds check
it out and we'll hopefully see you in
stores on the 15th